ladies und gentlemen meine damen und
herren ich darf sie recht herzlich zur
heutigen pressekonferenz anlässlich des
westbalkan dritten welt westbalkan
treffens begrüßen die
verteidigungsminister an meiner seite
sind aus albanien herr paloschi aus
bosnien und herzegowina
herr botsch aus montenegro frau
aus nord mazedonien frau schickeria aus
serbien herr stefanovic und als
gastgeberin die österreichische
verteidigungsministerin frau anna frau
verteidigungsminister ich darf sie um
ihre worte versuchen
geschätzte kolleginnen und kollegen
aus albanien herbe los bastian herr
botsch aus montenegro erinnert aus nord
mazedonien frau karin ska serbien ja
stefanovic geschätzte vertreter der
julia schediwy sehr geehrte damen und
herren der medien mit unseren partnern
am westbalkan verbindet uns eine
langjährige und eine aktive freundschaft
und es freut mich ganz besonders dass
wir es in dieser doch sehr
herausfordernden zeit geschafft haben
zusammen zu finden und somit den hier
anwesenden amtskolleginnen und kollegen
wichtige und notwendige gespräche zu
führen solche sicherheitspolitischen
dialoge im format von regionalen treffen
bilden eine wichtige grundlage für
nachfolgende bilaterale und regionale
aktivitäten
es werden oftmals thematiken der
höchsten sicherheitspolitischen und
militär strategischen ebene diskutiert
und diese diskurse und gespräche dienen
dann als ausgangspunkt für konkrete
vorhaben und projekte die mit
entsprechender unterstützung aus allen
entscheidungsebenen umgesetzt werden
können uns solche projekte haben wir
auch gemeinsam hier beschlossen an
dieser stelle schon ein ganz großes
dankeschön an meine kolleginnen und
kollegen bevor ich mehr auf diese
projekte eingehen darf ich doch noch
kurz erläutern welche rolle
österreicher für die akteure am
westbalkan spielt wir haben uns zum ziel
gesetzt die westbalkanstaaten auf ihrem
weg im rahmen des eu beitrittsprozesses
zu begleiten und negative einflüsse
externer staatlicher akteure nach
möglichkeit zu neutralisieren deswegen
haben wir auch in dieser wunderschönen
region eine neutrale plattform
geschaffen um den ländern die
möglichkeit zu geben
sicherheitspolitische dialoge zu führen
und diese möglichkeit die wurde in
vielerlei hinsicht und sehr ergiebig
genutzt die mit dem bundesministerium
für europäische und internationale
angelegenheiten
abgestimmte west balkan initiative des
bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung bezweckt vor allem
eines eine nachhaltige erhöhung der
sicherheitspolitischen stabilität der
westbalkanstaaten durch dialoge und
durch kapazitäten aufbau im rahmen
regionaler unter bilateraler
kooperationen diese aktivitäten sind
zeichen gegenseitiger wertschätzung und
bestätigen die bereits jetzt vorhandene
vertrauensbasis konkret haben wir uns
auf folgende vier bereiche geeinigt wo
wir maßnahmen setzen werden zum einen
die vertiefung des strategischen dialogs
durch minister-treffen durch bilaterale
gespräche und gemeinsame
themenbezogene workshops zum zweiten
einen gemeinsamen beitrag zur
nachhaltigen schließung der balkan route
durch ständigen austausch von lässt der
entsendung von mobilen trainings teams
sowie informations- und koordinations
formate zur migration zum dritten
übergang zum sicherheits provider durch
die teilnahme der westbalkanstaaten an
die eu und an un missionen
und zum vierten fähigkeitsentwicklung
durch steigerung der resilienz und der
interoperabilität
wichtig ist dabei bereits in der region
aktiv zu werden vor ort einen beitrag zu
leisten
dies wird bereits jetzt durch zahlreiche
gemeinsame ausbildungen wie zum beispiel
die offiziersausbildung durch
katastrophenschutz kurse kapazitäten
ausbauen bei cyber sicherheit und
alpinausbildung
forciert
mit dem dem ausbau dieser kapazitäten
sind wir überzeugt dass wir die residenz
der staaten steigern können und sind
überzeugt dass wir bei der entwicklung
vom sicherheits konsumenten zum
sicherheitsanbieter unterstützen und
hilfreich sein können es ist mir ein
bedürfnis mich bei meinen kolleginnen
und kollegen zu bedanken für die letzten
beiden tage für diese gute kooperation
und
auch für das was wir heute in so
harmonische atmosphäre an diesem
wunderschönen ort vereinbaren konnten
dankeschön
ich darf die medienvertreter nun um ihre
fragen ersuchen bitte zuerst diesem
medium zu nennen dann kriegen sie das
mikrofon und dann die frage an den
jeweiligen verteidigungsminister
beziehungsweise ministerin zu richten
gibt es fragen
bitte noch kurz zu warten bis das
mikrofon
ich möchte diese gelegenheit nutzen
und auch gleich eine frage stellen ich
selber weiß ich kann mir von styria
medien ich habe eine frage an herrn
stefanovic wir wissen ja selbst
die story adaptern ist um auf serbischen
boden mit russischen streitkräften eine
übung abgehalten gleichzeitig haben die
nato eine defender europe and even übung
abgehalten für die länder der region
waren sie eingeladen war serbien
eingeladen und wenn ja warum haben sie
nicht teilgenommen weiters eine frage
für
den vertreter bosnien herzegowinas herrn
bobic
die
niederlande behaupten dass auf dem boden
passiert so gut dass die gesamte
kontrolle der politischen und
militärischen strukturen die mutter
linie in roter jeans in den händen
halten und dass die militärischen
aktionen finanziert werden seitens der
islamischen staaten
das
meint der sicherheitsdienst
niederländische dass das alles einfluss
hat auch aus österreich weil die
geheimdienste bundes regelmäßig den
geheimdienst in österreich kein zeichen
übermitteln die
angeblich eine solche ausbildung in
bosnien zu gewinnen
also machen können sie das kommentieren
sehen sie das als eine gefahr für europa
war seitens bosnien herzegowina
vielen dank
sehr geehrte frau kollegin kannte ich
möchte mich anfangs bedanken bei frau
ministerin tanja für das ausgezeichnete
organisieren dieses treffen ist und all
das was wir hier besprechen konnten über
alle wichtigen themen betreffen die
regionale zusammenarbeit aber auch die
anbindung der gesamten region an die
europäische union danke an österreich
das kontinuierlich ein gehör dafür hat
und die aufmerksamkeit unsere länder
dabei zu unterstützen dass wir der eu
beitreten sind wichtige prozesse für
unsere völker das worüber wir heute
gesprochen haben unsere bilateralen
beziehungen werden es uns ermöglichen
dass unsere streitkräfte unsere
verteidigungsministerien besser die
chancen verstehen die europa und bietet
und durch eine gemeinsame projekte und
orale gemeinsamen operationen und unsere
commitment dass wir teil der
friedensmissionen über die eu sind dass
wir mehr interoperabel werden und uns
besser gegenseitig verstehen konkrete
frage als ein neutrales land hat serbien
es bevorzugt also und sich dazu
entschieden mit allen zusammen zu
arbeiten
wir haben fünf übungen bisher gemacht
mit den usa den nato mitgliedsstaaten
neben den usa weiteren mitgliedstaat
jetzt haben wir derzeit 2 laufen auf dem
gebiet sie haben eine übung mit ungarn
eine mit ungarn und den usa und der
luftstreitkräfte werden wir demnächst
eine haben mit den usa und serbien wo
mehrere hundert
fallschirmspringer haben werden gibt
einer großen übung teilnehmen werden und
130 flugzeuge auch der ansicht wenn wir
also dran ist land wählen es mit allen
zusammen zu arbeiten haben auch uns
entschieden mit der russischen
föderation zusammenzuarbeiten zwei
übungen mit der russischen föderation
dieses jahr gehabt wegen der situation
ansonsten waren geplant 40 49
geplant davon 27 nato staaten und den
usa und sechs mit der russischen
föderation weniger natürlich wurden
davon realisiert wie gesagt wegen der
kurve situation wir haben uns nicht
beteiligt an der defender europe übung
beteiligt weil kosovo eingeladen war in
einer weise wie wir das nicht anerkennen
die politik der republik serbien ist es
dass wir uns dann an solchen übungen
nicht beteiligen wurde so ist wir hätten
uns auch mit keiner anderen übung
beteiligt wo das der fall gewesen wäre
auch ungeachtet dessen ob es pro monat
organisiert war oder von russland alles
wo unsere souveränität in frage gestellt
wird da beteiligen uns an solchen
übungen nicht das ist die politik der
republik serbien wir führen eine politik
die vorsieht dass serbien der eu
beitritt das ist unser ziel das haben
wir hervorgehoben serbien sieht keine
andere zukunft
der rubikon ist überschritten worden der
würfel ist gefallen serbien hat sich
entschieden für eine eu-mitgliedschaft
und wir wollen unsere
verteidigungspolitik ich spreche für
mein ressort an dass der eu politik
anpassen damit wir in bälde ein
vollmitglied der europäischen union sind
unter unseren beitrag der gemeinsamen
sicherheitspolitik mit unseren kollegen
beitrag beitragen können wir bedanken
uns bei österreich das den beitritt
aller unserer länder zur eu unterstützt
und serbien unterstützt alle seine
nachbarländer
alle länder des westbalkans dass sie
auch mitglieder der europäischen union
werden vielen dank gibt es weitere
fragen
zunächst möchte ich alle hier ganz
herzlich begrüßen ich bedanke mich bei
der kollegin der frau minister tanna ich
bedanke mich auch für die bereitschaft
hierzu sprechen bei meinen kollegen aus
den westbalkan ländern wir haben heute
und gestern die möglichkeit gehabt
einige fragen zu analysieren wir sind
manchmal wirklich etwas unruhig
balkan aber wir sind überein gekommen
dass wir derzeit viel wichtigere dinge
haben sehr ernsthafte situation das
beste beispiel dafür ist die kurve
situation
wir haben hier
situationen die weder grenzen kennen
noch eine rasse nachnamen noch
religionsbekenntnis wir alle zusammen
müssen daran arbeiten die globalen
gefährdungen zu bekämpfen und etwas was
sie gerade gefragt haben nämlich
hinsichtlich ihrer frage über die
bedrohungen in bosnien herzegowina
dann möchte ich sagen dass die
migrations krise die route in bosnien
herzegowina wirklich eine bedrohung
besteht aber nicht in diesem sinne wie
sie gefragt haben frau kollegin frau
bastian herzig doch den herzegowina zeit
2016 sehr viel getan unsere bürger die
an den fronten in syrien teilgenommen
haben waren jene die dann auch zur
verantwortung gezogen erwarten und die
migrations rote entlang des balkans ist
eine andere frage
ich befasse mich mit diesen fragen schon
sehr lange diese migranten die wir am
westbalkan haben kommen zu uns aus der
eu aus griechenland aus rumänien und
anderen ländern bulgarien und als wir
dann die route nach ungarn blockiert
haben dann aber es so dass sehr viele
den weg über bosnien herzegowina gewählt
haben dann ist es zu einer totalen
blockade der kroatischen grenze gekommen
sodass diese unglücklichen menschen bei
uns sind aus den herzegowina geblieben
sind ca 3000 personen sind es wir hatten
deshalb wirklich ernsthafte probleme im
letzten jahr das zu lösen wir haben hier
interventionen gehabt über unsere
ministerien auch über unser
verteidigungsministerien um sie irgendwo
unterzubringen es wurden camps errichtet
und das was sie gefragt haben
bezüglich jetzt diese ausbildungscamps
ich verfüge über solche informationen
nicht wir haben in bosnien
nachrichtendienste sie wissen dass es
gibt sowohl dienste der eu über die
läufer als auch dienste in der
organisation der nato besser bis ihre
frage für mich etwas vielleicht lachhaft
wenn kroatien die grenzen öffnen lassen
wir alle diese leute weiter ziehen
danke christina schwacher von der
austria presse agentur
nachdem das thema migration ist schon
angesprochen worden ist ich würde
eigentlich gerne von allen ministern
wissen wie sie die die lage in ihren
ländern einsetzen weil in österreich
immer wieder der frage wann wird das
doch sehr viele eben darauf warten
weiter ziehen zu können und an die frau
ministerin tanne auch noch die frage
warum ist da costa bin nicht dabei
vielleicht zum ersten punkte was
migration
anbelangt wir sind überein gekommen dass
migration die herausforderung bleibt für
die region für uns alle unter der
westbalkan spielt ohne zweifel eine
schlüsselrolle in der frage wie wir in
zukunft mit der steigenden migration
umgehen werden wir sind überzeugt davon
dass wir diese herausforderung nur
gemeinsam
lösen können so zu ihrer zweiten frage
was den kosovo anbelangt doch das ist
diskutiert worden
wir sind überein gekommen wenn es eine
einstimmigkeit dazu gibt es
selbstverständlich die möglichkeit da
diesen kreis auch zu erweitern und wir
werden sicher darüber auch bei der
nächsten konferenz wiederum sprechen
ich darf den verteidigungsminister von
albanien bitte uns ein statement zur
migration ersuchen
vielen dank liebe bezüglich der
migrationsfrage auch albanien sowie
anderen west balkan länder befindet sich
in der situation als transitland
es gibt migration migrations strömungen
die
betreffen die sehen unsere länder als
auch albanien als ein transitland mit
dem ziel weitere eu-länder
natürlich albanien war und bleibt an
lang die die politik die gemeinsame
politik ein held der institutionen von
europa und der europäischen union wir
unsere stand haltung
ist sehr korrekt würde ich sagen
und nachhaltig in bezug auf die illegale
illegale grenzübertritte wir müssen
herausforderungen bewältigen und unsere
direktion der polizei bewältigt diese
herausforderungen erfolgreich
aber was die migrations strömungen
anbelangt und migrationsströme
afghanen
migrationsströme wir haben einige
hundert afghanen über luftweg luftbrücke
am flughafen empfangen und albanien hat
sich angeboten
afghanische flüchtlinge zu aufzunehmen
weil es gehört in der tradition der
albaner dass wir unsere gastfreundschaft
leute in not anbieten und dafür sind wir
stolz und wir
sind immer noch offen für weitere
afghanische flüchtlinge die auf flut
sind wegen den letzten bedrohungen zu
empfangen das hat er unsere
premierminister
offen gesagt dass sie auch in albanien
einen ein bischen bestimmte zahl von
denen auch auf dauer dass sie in
albanien leben und arbeiten vielen dank
steuerminister in motion
hat
schon gesagt vorhin
bedauerlicherweise ist es so dass wir
ein komplexes system in position inne
haben aufgrund unserer
staatsstruktur sehr häufig hier sind wie
zuständigen dienst der wegen einer sehr
langsamen
entscheidungsprozessen bin langsam
entscheidungsprozessen können sie nicht
so schnell entscheiden
wir helfen hier mit unseren
streitkräften hoffen dass wir in diesem
winter weil wir dieses
flüchtlingscamp eben cantona sana
fertigstellen werden diese flüchtlinge
die wir bereits haben dort unterbringen
werden können wie unser kollege aus
albanien gerade gemeint hat wir sind du
ein transitland also auch bosnien
herzegowina ist nur ein transit land und
sollten sie zb die grenze euro nach
kroatien passieren könnten diese
flüchtlinge würden sie sofort
weiterreisen
es wäre nicht korrekt wenn all diese
flüchtlinge ums zur last fallen im
westbalkan
also langsam guten tag ich möchte alle
hier ganz herzlich begrüßen und ich
möchte mich bei frau minister tana
bedanken so wie bei ihren mitarbeitern
für diese heutige initiative das ist die
fortsetzung des grads formats meiner
meinung nach ist es von großer bedeutung
bezüglich der bereitschaft der länder
der staaten am westbalkan für ihren
beitritt zur eu wir möchten deshalb auch
die zusammenarbeit im regionalen auch
den militärischen bereich sehen was die
frage der migration betrifft möchte ich
sagen dass montenegro früher nicht einen
großen flüchtlings druck ausgesetzt war
weil die route über nord mazedonien weil
das serbien bosnien-herzegowina und
kroatien viel aktiver war wir haben uns
in den vergangenen jahren vorbereitet
aber wir haben diesen großen drucken
bisher noch nicht verspürt jetzt sind
die zahlen ebenso niedriger als es in
den anderen ländern der fall ist aber
wir arbeiten sehr intensiv an dieser
frage auch unser
verteidigungsministerium das ministerium
montenegros arbeitet hier mit albanien
zusammen wir versuchen adäquate
mechanismen und modelle zu aufzubauen um
auch bei größeren migrationswellen
diesen standhalten zu können
wir erwarten so etwas nicht aber man
weiß nicht wie die trends sich
weiterentwickeln bezüglich der situation
in afghanistan aber erlauben sie mir
auch zu sagen dass wir als kleines land
auch in den vergangenen jahren als
wirklich ein guter gastgeber sich
gezeigt haben während der
auseinandersetzungen in bosnien
herzegowina beziehungsweise im kosovo
dass wir eine vielzahl an flüchtlingen
aufgenommen haben und falls wir auch in
zukunft
solchen situationen ausgesetzt werden
sollten werden wir sicherlich die
richtigen schritte setzen können dank
guten tag
ich gratuliere unserer kollegin der
österreichischen minister
verteidigungsministerin sie hat uns hier
alle eingeladen und wir haben einen
konsens erreicht über die wichtigen
fragen die in der region ich gratuliere
österreich weil sie ständig an der
agenda
auch in der eu arbeitet auch meine alle
meine kollegen haben dass kolleginnen
und kollegen haben das betont nord
mazedonien war
jahrelang teil der route von
flüchtlingen aus vielen ländern deren
ziel es war in ein westeuropäisches land
zu gelangen
seit 2005 10 bis heute haben wir gezeigt
dass wir ein land sind
mit dem österreich und die eu rechnen
können
wir haben in all diesen jahren eine gute
grenzkontrolle
gehabt und wie der bosnische kollege
gesagt hat
die
flüchtlinge kommen aus dominant aus
einem eu mitgliedsland wir haben unsere
aktion mit frontex koordiniert und mit
den
eu-mitgliedstaaten und bedeutete eine
starke unterstützung nicht nur durch die
polizei sondern auch durch die armee und
das
verteidigungsministerium seit 2015
haben wir
eine krisensituation an der grenze um
eine bessere kontrolle zu gewährleisten
das bleibt so angesichts der ereignisse
in afghanistan und wir erwarten dass der
druck auf denkt an den grenzen noch
höher sein wird
wenn über migration gesprochen wird sind
hier ein wichtiges thema und wir hoffen
dass es auch ein weiteres thema gibt und
für über uns und das ist das thema des
eu beitritts unseres landes zwei länder
haben schon die beitrittsgespräche mit
der eu begonnen und zwei warten auf den
beginn das sind albanien und mazedonien
wir haben als staaten sehr viel im
bereich der reformen im land getan
im bereich der lösung regionaler
probleme und wir haben die eu auch in
der migranten krise geholfen
wir hoffen dass auch diese frage bald
gelöst wird und wir bald gebäudes
gespräche mit der eu beginnen können
nord mazedonien und albanien haben
nach den tragischen ereignissen in kabul
entschieden
migranten auf bestimmte zeit bei uns
aufzunehmen
ähnlich wie andere länder haben wir
gesagt dass wir aufgrund unserer
geschichte dazu verpflichtet sind denn
in mazedonien die mazedonier gibt es
eine tragische geschichte von
auswanderungen mazedonischen
flüchtlingen den der in europa und in
asien aufgenommen wurden und das haben
deswegen sind wir der meinung dass wir
in dieser krise bewusst vieler
persönlichen tragödien und frauen und
familien in afghanistan diese
flüchtlinge bei uns aufzunehmen vielen
dank postl ist
eine schwere frage gestellt warum eine
schwere frage weil leider seit 2015 als
wir millionen weise dieser
flüchtlingsströme haben europa bisher
wir keine antwort gefunden habe auf die
wesentlichste frage und zwar was europa
eigentlich will was ist die einheitliche
politik des der gesamten europäischen
union wenn die europäische union die es
mit der wir verhandeln und gespräche
führen 780 bemüht in diesem zeitraum ich
war damals innenminister und bin sehr
gut vertraut mit diesem thema serbien
hat sich bemüht dass wir die botschaft
aussenden dass wenn wir europa vor einer
illegalen migration verteidigen dann
muss es an den grenzen europas sein ganz
egal ob wir mit staaten sind oder nicht
weil wir serbien und nord mazedonien
waren die ersten auf dieser route an die
diese migrantenströme gestoßen sind eine
million über eine million migranten
ist über serbien auf dem weg gewesen
nach westeuropa wir hatten sehr gut das
verstehe ich habe verständnis für
österreich ungarn und tschechien die uns
als erste geholfen haben und kontingente
geschickt haben nach nord mazedonien und
unsere polizeibeamten auch gemeinsam mit
den nord
mazedonischen polizeibeamten und den
kollegen aus frontex waren an den
grenzen griechenlands wo wir diese
illegale migration aufhalten wollten
österreich hat sehr viel investiert ich
glaube ministerin johanna mikl leitner
was damals und später herr minister
sobotka haben sehr viel investiert also
österreich um diese illegale migration
durch alle unsere ländern aufzuhalten
überall die massenweisen schlepper wo
menschen ihr leben verloren weil diese
komponente der kriminalität da auch sich
beteiligt hat an der gesamten route vom
anfang an also von beginn der migration
bis zu den zielen
wir haben hier eine starke botschaft
ausgesandt dass das nicht toleriert
werden wird nach all diesen ereignissen
jetzt in afghanistan stellt sich die
frage was machen wir wenn jetzt die
kältere jahreszeit vor der tür steht wir
werden vielleicht nicht so eine
ausgeprägte migration haben wir damals
aber was passiert im frühling jetzt muss
europa uns eine antwort geben uns die
wir nicht mitgliedstaaten sind was
erwartet die eu von uns erwartet die eu
das für diese menschen gemeinsam
irgendwo aufhalten kontrollieren
registrieren ihnen die durchreise
verwehren oder ihnen die durchreise
erlauben unter welchen bedingungen auf
welche weise sollen wir vorgehen sollen
wir deren wünsche respektieren oder
nicht das sind die fragen wo unsere
relativ kleinen länder selbst keine
antwort geben können und mich in der
position sind sie eine antwort zu geben
im namen der republik serbien kann ich
nur sagen dass wir bereit sind mit
unseren kräften die
legalität unserer grenzen schützen
werden wir können nicht durch die
illegale einreise erlauben dass unsere
gesetze gewann sie gegen unsere gesetze
verstoßen wird mit der unterstützung der
europäischen union haben wir bestimmte
kapazitäten aufgebaut bestimmte aufnahme
camps für migranten und natürlich wir
waren uns vollkommen bewusst dass ich
nicht mit einer vielzahl der menschen
gesprochen
sie hatten nur die absicht erklärt dass
die asyl verlangen asylansuchen wollen
in serbien aber eigentlich weiterreisen
wollen nach westeuropa ungeachtet der
unterschiedlichen politiken gewisser
mitgliedstaaten der eu
glaube ich dass wir eine gute gemeinsame
antwort gefunden haben wie wir ein
minimum des gemeinsamen anwenden können
das system immerhin auf eine auf ebene
der legalität anderem bringen können
jetzt stellen sich fragen die wir
definieren müssen ob wir nämlich eine
gemeinsame antwort haben werden oder
wieder zurückfallen auf die situation
215 von 215 wo sich jeder selbst
zurechtfinden muss ich möchte nicht
jedenfalls bei kollegin skoda nord
mazedonien hier bedanken allem für all
die unterstützung die wir bisher hatten
wir haben gemeinsame streifen hier mit
allen staaten die uns umgeben wir
möchten mit dieser auf diese weise die
botschaft aussenden dass man das gesetz
achten muss und weil wir ein start sind
dass der eu beitreten möchten wir bitten
die eu uns zu helfen uns richtlinien
leitlinien gibt wie wir verfahren sollen
und wir danken allen jenem beamtendienst
geholfen haben an unseren grenzen
unterstützt haben mit der ausrüstung wie
wärmebildkameras und so weiter wir
möchten diesen menschen die immerhin
menschliche wesen sind wir werden sie
nicht als menschen zweiter dritten
ranges behandelt aber wir müssen ihnen
klar die botschaft aussenden schicken
dass sich jeder irgendwo hin ohne sich
zu fragen über willkommen iss aufbrechen
kann in ein anderes land
wenn nicht darf ich mich recht herzlich
bedanken und erkläre die pressekonferenz
für beendet